train if you know what these little
black dots are you wanna let the whole
black doctor make a red rose street
fighter bag the G
Oh
and cut so sorry for the audio quality
yeah we're just using the onboard mic
Ted's here from aperture so let's go the
reason why Ted's here with the aperture
halo right now is if you look at a bunch
of the footage you can see that under
everyone's eyes is pretty shadow and
pretty dark until we actually start
lighting them and stuff well we have to
light them with another light also by
aperture hello that's another lighting
and that can get a pain in the butt when
you're kinda just running and going and
you just need to see someone's eyes so
if we put the halo all on the lens or
right above it whichever one you get a
nice eye light we can fill in those
shadows so you guys can always see
everyone's face and eyes that's the idea
so Nick and Carmichael are about to
fight for this awesome Street Fighter
Academy bag I want to see a fight to the
death
whoever lives they get the bag if I
don't wanna
following your head dad said right
before I killed what your mom said why
thank you we have rules kind of
disqualifies some certain hits hands
don't count facing the blade does not
count edge only counts how we do it I
tend to go a bit more defense and then
counter-attack I like to get in there
cut him up and just walk away
come on really yummy you're too cute
super small pocketable internal LED
battery chargeable by USB or to six
hours Spencer got it up and running and
working great but at the wide lens that
I'm using you got a little problem the
lights in the shot so we're going to do
we're actually going to take it off the
lens dim that down I got controls right
here all right I'm rolling so but now
super dark that's a huge difference
right there huge difference put your
defeated honor and pride inside that bag
take it to the gym can't wait to fill up
that bag full gone up and go visit your
mom
sudden death that was a challenging
battle and they really gave it all they
couldn't that last round respective
perspectives a lot of you out there who
shoot videos and photos you know what
this is
Israeli arm the right there so hold that
for sorry
tighten it up so what the big issue with
this is you mount this on the camera and
someone just comes by and goes oh let me
see that and they just twisted this is
what it's like it's all tight and locked
and they're just breaking that the
friend much effort you're not just like
ah why'd you do that I just spent a
hundred and fifty dollars on that this
guy
I can't do it I thought you're strong
son Michael not as strong but look I can
do it you do it due to the aperture one
look she an anti idiot Israeli armed for
40 bucks so if you make a video on
YouTube talking about products people
are going to accuse you of making the
advertisement in this case we didn't get
paid to say any of this stuff
we're just fans of apertures equipment
it's affordable and it's useful and we
use the lights those point lights
especially nearly every day and there's
no better testament than that a lot of
you guys who watch our channel are
filmmakers yourselves and we figured we
should pass on the good word if there's
something that's affordable and works
great those single source lights have my
full endorsement I love them
alright thanks yeah yeah that was my
sign